and on the mound for the raise lewis
head against this detroit ball club
you'd like to see a quick start here for
lewis head maybe a couple of innings
clean so two outs of the base is empty
for miguel cabrera the 3-2 pitch
breaking ball strike three called at the
top of the zone
cabrera didn't like the call from home
point up by vic karapaza but he gets
rung up and here's the left-hander tyler
alexander at one point in time a
second-round pick for the tigers in 2015
out of texas christian university he uh
was decent against the race through four
innings his last timeout gave up just
the one run lefty works from the stretch
as we get things started against yandy
diaz and the first pitch here is lifted
to the gap in left center field and deep
back to the wall and gone
yandi diaz on the first pitch he sees
here on the bottom of the first has hit
it out it's his 11th home run of the
season and he gives the raise a one
nothing lead he has now faced alexander
three times three played appearances he
has a walk
a base hit and a home run so homer
and narrow walk and nelson cruz coming
up oh that pitch gets cruz got him on
the hand comes away shaking that hand
the raves will come out to take a look
at him trying to drive that pitch in
right off the outside of that right
forearm yeah slid by the hand i'll take
it on the outside of the forearm all day
long and he'll be just fine two men in
scoring position
fly ball
not too deep to left center house is
there to make the catch
tag at third margaux will score
and the range turned that into a run
it's two
chamber candelario eric haas and nico
goodrim do up for detroit and they will
do so against a new pitcher dietrich
ends
candelario
switch hitting third baseman out on
strikes
is up swinging in a miss
he struck him out so dietrich
two batters in is pretty much picked up
right where he left off that'll bring up
nico goodroom
it's a liner in the left gonna be in a
base head couple hops out to her rose
arena so first hit of the day for the
tigers like a slider that didn't slide
runner takes off a throw to first a
little double pump there by
luke lowe but they still get him on the
throw down to second
lao
put the tag on him
so technically
they caught stealing and we're going to
see if the tigers want to challenge it
and uh he is out they're not going to
challenge it and the layoff man is
aboard this is derek hill
ground ball right side
down to second they get the force play
there wendell got over to take the throw
on the fielder's choice hill at first
and now robbie grossman another throw to
first they got him picked the throw from
luplow down to second and hill is picked
on
a cart stealing one to three to four
that's the second one that ends has
gotten today back to the top of the
order as we go to the third and yandy
diaz
there's a liner and a base hit in the
left he has another hit off alexander
and he's aboard to begin to raise half
of the third gandhi still did first with
two down here in the third inning
down the right field line long run for
robbie grossman he almost overran it
back pendleton makes the catch and
another quick easy inning
for tyler alexander tyler alexander
despite struggling in the first has
really settled in nicely he's needed
just 17 pitches in the last two innings
faces brandon loud 1-2 and he strikes
out brandon lau to start the fourth and
two up and two down with this low pitch
count two-nothing lead in the bottom of
the fourth inning and a dandy bunt put
down there
by joey wendell they were pretty much
giving him that left line
the third base line on the left side
there and he put down a dandy you get
the power right-handed bat of mike
zenino at the plate against a lefty
zanino swings it's a fly ball to left
playable though going back and coming in
now eric haas to make the easy grab i
think he got in maybe just a little bit
toward the trademark
menino didn't get all of it and it's an
easy out number three nico goodram
singled his first time up but then was
caught stealing good rum sends one to
deep left center field kirimaire
tracking it that ball is gone a home run
for nico goodroom his seventh of the
season puts detroit on the board you
know it sounded good off the bat it was
a matter of watching the two outfielders
as they kind of came together out there
and left center field i didn't see that
kill mario opened up open the gate randy
rosarina pounds his stomach and says get
back where you belong second longest
homer of the season for nico goodwin so
one out runner at second base and a
chance for manuel margot and the pitch
he breaks for third this one lied almost
hit caremeyer diving stopped by goodrum
his throw to first not in time it gets
away here comes kiermeier and he will
score and the rays take a three to one
lead as they run the bases and the
tigers
can't make a plug
kirby for justin instant wasn't sure
where it was going and then picked it up
and as he saw the play being made he was
a third he made a dance home turns out
to be academic on this throw to first it
got away and the rays pick up their
third run so it's a three one raised
lead carlton will face mike zenino with
a man at first and two outs in the sixth
that's a high fly ball back into deep
center hill will go to the wall good bye
1-0 pitch and zenino hits it out to the
deep part of the park and the rays now
lead 5-1 and just like that the rays
pushed that lead out by a couple more
31st home run of the year for mike
zanino three bases on balls in
succession so the bases are loaded
austin meadows will hit in the place of
cruz the pitch popped up in the shallow
left coming in for it as high as a late
break and then he gets there to make the
catch and that will retire may remember
nelson cruz left the game after being
hit by a pitch early in the game the
good news is x-rays were negative and i
am told that it is a right forearm
contusion guys it's two outs man on
we're in the bottom of the seventh
inning the payoff
right back off his heel in the air good
room from the bare hand play and a
beautiful play from nico goodroom wow
kicked off of kroll jump bear hand
landed through and got him at first base
the rays will not challenge first time
tonight the tigers will have an at-bat
with a man in scoring position and now
they have minute first and second one
out of the eighth
ground ball right to walls to second
burnout wow the first and they're out of
the inning a double play a texan a
double play
and the tigers are turned away in the
eighth kevin kiermeier draws a four
pitch walk here's yandy diaz lines one
and a half to second diving to his left
castro the second fern out good jumps
turn to first and the tigers turn a
double play and that one that was the
thing of beauty great stop by castro
strong feed to good room last shot for
the tigers we head to the ninth inning
it's five one raise on to the ninth we
go jt chagawa is pitcher number six for
the race tonight and there's two going
here in the night now it's up to jamer
candelario to keep the inning alive
and a fly ball deep right field gamer
candelario put a charge into that one a
solo homer to keep the game alive his
15th of the season the tigers have cut
it to five to two so here's eric haas
he's over three
that's gonna do it swinging at a base
razor winners
so the raids win their 91st game of the
year reducing the magic number for the
raise to seven